der dasa aus punkt damit erledigt ich
rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 5
vereinbarte debatte zur konferenz zur
zukunft
europas für die ausfahrten dauer von mir
was ist die konferenz zur zukunft
europas beteiligung statt bürokratie mit
groß angelegten bürger debatten will die
eu neue ware und transparenter werden
die konferenz zur zukunft europas wurde
am 9 mai 2021 im europaparlament
gestartet sie besteht aus einer vielzahl
von veranstaltungen und einer zentralen
online plattform auf beiden wegen können
bürgerinnen und bürger ihre ideen für
die zukunft der eu äußern ein ausschuss
aus vertretern und vertreterinnen von
parlament eu kommission und rat der eu
soll dies bündeln und den drei organen
vorstellen oder die erste rednerin zu
diesem punkt ist die staatsministerin im
auswärtigen amt anna lührmann die für
den bereich europa und klima energie
zuständig ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
für die demokratie ist diese pandemie
eine enorme herausforderung
das merken die bürgerinnen und bürger
das merken wie abgeordnete im parlament
alltag
umso bemerkenswerter ist es dass europa
mitten in der pandemie das größte
experiment aller zeiten zur besseren
beteiligung der bürgerinnen und bürger
gestartet hat die zukunftskonferenz
damit beweist die eu dass die
europäische demokratie sehr wohl
funktioniert und sehr wohl lebendig ist
dass sie mit immer neuen ideen
bürgerinnen und bürger besser beteiligen
will liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
zukunftskonferenz ist ein booster für
die europäische demokratie
und darf liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist doch wirklich ein grund stolz zu
sein auf europa und vertrauen in die
demokratie zu haben
die eu hat erstmals alle europäerinnen
und europäer und konkrete ideen zur
zukunft europas gebeten über eine
webseite in den europäischen und in den
nationalen bürger dialogen in der
zukunftskonferenz im auswärtigen amt
haben wir kürzlich ein nationales
bürgerforum wird über 100 größten
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmern
organisiert ganz besonders beeindruckt
hat mich der enthusiasmus der
teilnehmenden die ideen sprudelten nur
so und am letzten wochenende haben wir
in straßburg einige von ihnen waren
dabei begonnen uns in der
zukunftskonferenz mit den vorschlägen
auseinanderzusetzen
das war insgesamt eine sehr konstruktive
debatte mit politikerinnen und
politikern aus dem europäischen
parlament aus den nationalen parlamenten
und regierungen
aber es gab auch zwei arten von
wortmeldungen die mich sehr nachdenklich
gemacht haben
manche rednerinnen und redner waren
extrem ablehnend gegenüber den
vorschlägen der bürgerinnen und bürger
das geht so nicht das haben wir doch
noch nie so gemacht die eu sei gut so
wie sie das
andere haben versucht die bürgerinnen
und bürger zu vereinnahmen
entweder für ihre eigenen zwecke oder
indem sie einfach das blaue vom himmel
herunter herunter versprochen haben wir
setzen das jetzt alles sofort um wurde
da gesagt
beides ist nicht die antwort der
bundesregierung
sondern wir werden uns ernsthaft mit den
vorschlägen der bürgerinnen und bürger
auseinandersetzen
da gibt es nämlich ideen da frage ich
mich warum machen wir das nicht schon
längst so mit einem onboarding paket
soll jedem und jeder informationen über
europäische werte zur verfügung gestellt
werden viele andere konkrete ideen für
mehr beteiligung und für eine
europäische öffentlichkeit eine eu tv
wurden auf vorgelegt dann gibt es
großartige ideen die kosten aber sehr
viel geld ich war ja mit mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
da würden werde dann sicherlich sehr
genau
darüber reden müssen und gemeinsam dafür
kämpfen so was in den haushalten
unterzubringen zum beispiel eu-förderung
für schüleraustausch und
es gibt vorschläge die so ähnlich sind
wie vor haben die wir gerade schon in
brüssel oder auch hier im bundestag sehr
intensiv diskutieren
dazu gehört zum beispiel die grenz
abgabe beim import klimaschädlicher
produkte eine garantierte lebensdauer
einen lebenszyklus von produkten
mindestlohn hier müssen die vorschläge
der bürgerinnen und bürger wirklich
konkret in den prozess einfließen
und zwar eine ernsthafte debatte gehört
es aber auch klar zu sagen es gibt auch
vorschläge die vermutlich schwer
umzusetzen sein werden aus technischen
gründen zum beispiel alles nicht
funktionieren kann so ist das eben bei
einem brainstorming prozess da kommen
viele ideen raus und einige davon muss
man dann wieder verwerfen bei anderen
vorschlägen kommt die eu an die grenzen
ihrer handlungsfähigkeit zum beispiel
für ihre werte nach innen aber auch nach
außen entschieden eintreten deshalb
lautet ein vorschlag auch die regeln der
einstimmigkeit zu überprüfen solche
debatten müssen wir jetzt gemeinsam
ambitioniert und entschlossen angehen
denn ein starkes europa ist ein europa
das die empfehlung seiner bürgerinnen
und bürger wirklich ernst nimmt dass die
anregungen nicht in einer schublade
verschwinden lässt sondern wege findet
wie die besten davon auch realität
werden können und dabei setzt sich auf
ihre unterstützung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ministerin ja und zentrales gremium ist
das sogenannte plenum dem 433 menschen
angehören sollen neben politikern aus
den eu-staaten den nationalen
parlamenten und dem europaparlament er
auch zufällig ausgewählte normale
menschen nicht normal ist gunther
krichbaum den erster sprecher für europa
politik der union und er war dabei
genauso wie zum beispiel axel schäfer
sein kollege von der spd als es vor
einer woche zur dritten sitzung ging
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen die zukunftskonferenz ist schon
jetzt ein erfolg denn es gibt einen
positiven schub bei den bürgerinnen
bürgern in europa man debattiert und
diskutiert über europa quer durch die
republik quer durch europa hindurch auch
in meiner heimatstadt in pforzheim eine
stadt mit sehr hohem
migrationshintergrund debattiert man und
streitet man leidenschaftlich über und
für die europäischen themen das thema
europa findet eingang in die schulen
aber bei lichte besehen müssen wir auch
sagen es ist noch mächtig luft nach oben
hier würde ich mir zb auch gerade von
den ländern wünschen dass dieses thema
noch stärker über die
kultusministerkonferenz in die schulen
eingespeist wird und wir gerade auch bei
der jungen generation hier für einen
positiven aufschlag sorgen wir müssen
uns mit diesen vorschlägen die die
bürger machen auseinandersetzen und frau
staatsministerin wirmann hat es auch
gerade schon angesprochen
einer der wünsche aus der bürgerschaft
heraus ist beispielsweise der wunsch
nach mehr strategischer autonomie in
europa in der welt
wenn wir das sehen dann müssen wir uns
in der tat kritisch die frage stellen ob
wir noch weltpolitik fähig sind das
bedeutet mit blick beispielsweise auf
china das china sehr wohl eine strategie
hat für europa auf afrika aber wir
umgekehrt keine für china
auch hier lohnt sich ein blick auf die
unterschiedlichen verhältnisse wird
debattieren wir debattieren hier
leidenschaftlich in deutschland in
europa ob wir huawei auf den
europäischen markt lassen sollen ja oder
nein bei lichte besehen ist das aber gar
keine frage über huawei sondern das
problem liegt darin dass wir keine
europäische antwort haben dass wir kein
european oder besser gesagt global
player haben der hier huawei das wasser
reichen könnte
überdies
wird die debattieren dann darüber ob wir
es zulassen dürfen dass wir gemeinsame
züge bauen dürfen mit als strom und
siemens aber wir versperren uns über das
wettbewerbsrecht der europäischen union
wertvolle wege die wir brauchen um hier
in der globalisierung bestehen zu können
auch das ist wichtig wenn wir eine
strategische autonomie anstreben wollen
eine andere entwicklung die wir in
deutschland eigentlich kaum wahrnehmen
jedenfalls eine diskussion die wir nicht
führen eine konzentration auf dem
finanzdienstleistungsmarkt schauen wir
auf die zehn größten banken gemessen am
börsenwert dann findet sich darunter
keine einzige europäische bank fünf
kommen aus china fünf kommen aus den usa
noch brutaler und dramatisch fällt der
blick auf wenn wir auf die glanz die
vier größten banken kommen alle aus hier
was bedeutet das jetzt für uns in europa
jeder jeder bürger jede bürgerin und
jeder bürger der stadt und die schon mal
eine finanzierung hat machen müssen weiß
dass man vor das geld fließt die daten
fließen müssen das heißt jedes
unternehmen wenn sie china im
europäischen markt investiert muss daten
liefern
ermöglicht damit den einblick in die
herzkammer eines unternehmens dh auch an
dieser stelle müssen wir aufpassen dass
wir uns strategisch klug genug
aufstellen denn es geht nicht nur um die
unternehmen sondern auch um die
volkswirtschaften und der einfluss
chinas in der welt und vor allem in
europa steigt natürlich
wenn wir über die weltpolitik fähigkeit
reden und dem wunsch nach mehr
strategische autonomie dann geht es
natürlich auch um die ukraine
die ukraine warum gerade debatten
gegenstand deswegen möchte ich mir da
weitere ausführungen auch sparen aber es
fällt natürlich schon auf das aktuell
die gespräche in genf laufen über
zentrale europäische sicherheitsfragen
aber europa hier nicht mit am tisch
verhandelt und nicht mit am tisch sitzt
unsere entscheidung ist derweil klar die
ukraine ist ein souveränes land und es
ist zunächst einmal die entscheidung
dieser länder ob sie sich den standards
der europäischen union annähern wollen
oder nicht aber wenn das wie im falle
der euro der ukraine dann auch erfolgt
ist dann kann es nicht sein dass
russland hier ein mitspracherecht für
sich reklamiert das sollte auch herrn
gysi eigentlich klar sein denn würde man
das zubilligen wollen dann wäre das ein
revival dann wäre das eine
wiederbelebung der breschnew doktrin
aber brechen das ist genau so tot wie
die bresche news doktrin es sein sollten
wenn wir
überhaupt auf russland schauen dann
werden wir an einem punkt immer
auseinander liegen das was wir als
unsere werte betrachten der freiheit der
rechtsstaatlichkeit der demokratie sind
aus sicht von herrn putin reale
bedrohungslage er kann mit freiheit
genauso wenig anfangen wie mit
demokratie eine forderungen und frau
löhrmann sie wissen es ja mit dabei
waren ist auch die frage nach einer
europäischen armee dabei wird ein stück
weit übersehen dass wir ja schon im
prozess der verstärkten zusammenarbeit
pascoe auf den weg gebracht haben das
willige länder die hier vorangehen
wollen können es dann auch tun und
machen es dann auch aber bis zu einer
europäischen armee ist es noch ein sehr
weiter schritt und ein sehr weiter weg
denn das würde zunächst einmal bedeuten
dass wir schon mal beim
beschaffungswesen
einheitliche standards bekommen aber
auch hier gibt es keine europaweiten
ausschreibungen weil mit blick auf
frankreich sich auch einzelne nationale
mitgliedsländer dagegen wehren aber auch
an die eigene adresse gesprochen wenn
wir tatsächlich den verteidigungsbereich
europäisieren möchten dann heißt das
auch im klartext dass er von den
weltweit strengsten
rüstungsexport gesetzen die wir nun mal
haben auch abstriche machen müssen sonst
kommen wir hier zu keiner echten
europäisierung ich möchte schließen
damit dass die zukunftskonferenz sehr
sehr viele gute ideen liefert auch
positionen vermittelt die uns zu einer
rückbesinnung
verpflichtet denn wir müssen jetzt auch
schauen dass wir dieser
zukunftskonferenz eine zukunft geben ich
möchte da ausdrücklich die partner die
projektpartner ermutigen weiterzumachen
frau hatten beispielsweise von parks of
europe steckt enorm viel engagement
hinein und wenn wir als parlamentarier
europäisches parlament nationale
parlamente diese idee nicht aufgreifen
und diskutieren dann würde sehr viel
enttäuschung zurück bleiben und das wäre
es das wäre fatal das können wir nicht
wollen und ich freue mich deswegen jetzt
auf eine fortsetzung auch dieses
prozesses im mai noch während der
ratspräsidentschaft der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft wird dann wohl der
abschluss bereich vorgelegt werden aber
wie gesagt weitermachen ist deswegen
sinnvoll weil wir dann viele weitere
menschen für das europäische projekt
auch begeistern können vielen dank
vergangene woche freitag und samstag
fand die dritte plenarsitzung in
straßburg statt gunther krichbaum war da
aber auch der nächste redner axel
schäfer sie nahmen als vertreter der
konstanz für den deutschen minister teil
ich kann zu drücken das widerstrebt mir
natürlich etwas mache ich trotzdem die
zahl der waren ist gleich vorbei ist
noch ein mittel des hauses anwesend dass
seine stimme nicht abgegeben hat
ich erkenne das ist nicht der fall ist
rennt auch niemand mehr auf der
westempore
also alle kollegen folgen haben ihre
stimme abgegeben dann schließe ich die
wahlen bitte die schriftführer
schriftführer mit der ausbildung zu
beginnen die ergebnisse der wahlen
werden später bekanntgegeben wir kehren
handelt es sich aus war es im
richterwahlausschuss die abgeordneten
hatten jetzt 100 minuten zeit hier ihre
stimmkarten abzugeben jetzt also ist es
beendet und ich hatte ihn angesprochen
als sieht auch er war bei dieser dritten
plenarsitzung vergangene woche dabei für
die spd
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir haben eine vereinbare
debatte über die zukunft europas es hat
länger gedauert zu dieser vereinbarung
zu kommen als zum beispiel eine fraktion
sich das gewünscht hätte und es hat auch
was mit dem zustand europas zu tun
vieles dauert leider länger als die
überzeugten föderalisten und
föderalisten sich das wünschen aber wir
sind jetzt tatsächlich an einem punkt
angekommen wo wir sagen müssen dürfen
auch können ja wir befinden uns auf der
höhe der zeit wir befinden uns auf der
höhe der zeit
wo eine große mehrheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger für mehr europäische
zusammenarbeit für mehr europäischen
zusammenhalt aber auch für mehr
europäischen zusammenschluss sich
ausspricht und gleichzeitig eine leider
wachsende minderheit für nationalismus
für abgrenzung und ausgrenzung sich
lauthals artikuliert und gerade wir
wissen
nationalismus ist ein irrtum der auf
einem irrweg führt und in einem ihr sind
nämlich krieg endet und deshalb ist
dieses europäische diese europäische
aufgabe eben die aufgabe des friedens
und gegen jegliche form des
nationalismus
und wir sind deshalb auf der höhe der
zeit weil zum ersten mal in europa über
den fortschritt eben nicht nur die am
beginn des einigungsprozesses vor 70
jahren die regierungen standen später
ein parlament was zwar viel zu sagen
aber nicht zu entscheiden hatte sondern
jetzt das europäische parlament
gleichberechtigt mit den nationalen
parlamenten und einer gleichen zahl von
engagierten bürgerinnen und bürgern
diskutieren und vorschläge machen und
das sollten wir aufnehmen das sollten
wir ernst nehmen und das sollten wir
voranbringen gerade hier liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen im deutschen
bundestag und diese besondere
verpflichtung zeigt sich auch und ich
finde das sollten wir gemeinsam in den
demokratischen parteien stolz sein dass
der austausch zwischen den parlamenten
bei uns bisher schon ziemlich gut
funktioniert haben wir haben hier von
friedrich merz über alexander graf
lambsdorff claudia roth auch bis hin zu
sahra wagenknecht und ich gehöre auch zu
dieser riege kolleginnen und kollegen
die schon im europäischen parlament
waren und jetzt im bundestag sind und wo
es deutlich darauf ankommt dass wir die
rechte des europäischen parlaments
stärken ihre demokratischen
möglichkeiten ausbauen dass eine
zentrale forderung der bürgerinnen und
bürger mit denen wir bisher auf der
zukunftskonferenz diskutierte
und und dazu gehört natürlich immer auch
dass wir mit dem anfangen was schon
heute möglich ist und aus übrigens gar
kein geld kostet ich appelliere noch mal
daran dass wir im deutschen bundestag
ebenso wie im europäischen parlament
eine öffentliche debatte auch in den
ausschüssen führen auch das ist für die
beteiligung von bürgerinnen und bürgern
so wichtig und dass wir auch die
konsequenzen bei der nächsten europawahl
mit trans und sammlern listen und vielen
anderen möglichkeiten auch hier im
deutschen bundestag
diskutieren und entscheiden und nicht
sagen wir warten bis alle anderen auch
dafür sind sonne ein stückchen wieder
eine vorreiterrolle einnehmen wie es
unsere vorväter oder mütter hier getan
haben die als erste gefordert haben die
direktwahl eines europäischen
parlamentes weit bevor das 1978 79
beschlossen ist und
sieben kolleginnen kollegen ich will an
dieser stelle es ist von vorredner
gunther krichbaum danken zweiter weise
auch schon getan worden noch einmal an
die länder auch appellieren sie sind da
sehr stark repräsentiert mit
ministerinnen
staatssekretärinnen und auch
parlamentspräsidentin erfreulich viele
frauen dass auch das bitteschön die
aufgabe von parlamenten in den ländern
ist dass das diskutiert wird genauso wie
das zu den demokratischen politischen
fraktionen dort gehört
und ich appelliere auch und wir sind ja
alle in wahlkreisen beheimatet wir
wohnen ja in städten und gemeinden
deshalb
appelliere ich an die kommunale ebene
das zu tun was die spitzenverbände auch
formuliert gefordert erwartet haben
nämlich dieses thema zukunft europas
weil die menschen eben vor ort leben und
nicht irgendwo in ländern auch zu einer
sache der debatten der ratssitzung der
gemeindevertretung vor ort zu machen das
findet sein wir doch ganz ehrlich das
findet zurzeit viel zu wenig statt
deshalb sollten wir das auch ermutigend
ich werde meinen persönlichen beitrag
leisten und meine ehefrau
bürgermeisterin in diesem sinne auch ein
stückchen zusätzlich ermutigen ich gehe
davon aus dass sie das auch so wieso
macht
man könnte das ist nur die gleiche
partei familie und die gleiche
europäische überzeugen die ich mit
meiner lieben frau seit 50 jahren teil
ja liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
entscheidend ist ja immer der prozess
das heißt die diskussion dass wir sie
führen und wie wir sie führen aber der
prozess muss auch zu ergebnissen
niemals zu abschließenden aber doch zu
zukunfts führenden ergebnissen führen
und deshalb ist es doch so wichtig dass
das was hier gelungen ist mit der neuen
koalition und in einem koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart und der besondere
verantwortung der drei parteien dass das
auch umgesetzt werden dass wir das hier
auch wiederholen ja wohl diese
bundesregierung diese mehrheit des
bundestages hat festgehalten die
ergebnisse der konferenz zur zukunft
europas werden wir nehmen aufnehmen
ernst nehmen und mit diesen ergebnissen
zb fordern dass es einen konvent gibt
der auch vertragsveränderungen in den
europäischen verträgen ermöglicht um
tatsächlich auf dem weg einer
fortschreitenden integration
voranzukommen das ist ein versprechen
und das werden wir hier gemeinsam halten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die idee
zur zukunftskonferenz europas kam vom
französischen präsidenten
im manual marco ich bedauere es sehr
dass wir damals in deutschland nicht
mutiger mit einer antwort und einer
zustimmung gewesen sind lasst uns das
heute ein stückchen nachholen und lasst
uns das gleichzeitig in europa mit
unseren französischen
anderen partnerinnen die für diese
gemeinschaft sind und gegen den
nationalismus lasst uns das in die tat
umsetzen durch mutige debatten und auch
den zu widersprechen die gegen europa
sind vielen dank
vielen dank der abschlussbericht soll
dieses feuer fertig sein als grund dafür
gilt weiterhin die präsidentschaftswahl
in frankreich amtsinhaber microsoft mit
dem von ihm angestoßenen reformprozess
habe ich eine bitte die
anwesenden schritt für schritt für uns
fehlen frauen männer zum auszählen der
stimmzettel schriftführer raum befinden
sich nur wenige kollegen die alleine
wahrscheinlich zwei bis drei stunden
brauchen würden um die aussendung er war
ein vorzunehmen als schriftführer die
noch hier sind würde ich bitten oder die
an den fernseher sitzen oder der
umstände eine radiogeräten zu höheren
mieten dort sich in den schriften zu
begehen wir frühzeitig ergebnis gekommen
dass ich ein tolles ding die schon
früher sind heute gewählt worden und
dann sind sie alle gegangen zum feiern
wo auch immer in der tat brauchte
schriftführer um diese 736 dem nd sein
können und aussetzen
der merkbar machen aber so dass sie nur
mein klopfen hören und ich werde erst
mich verbal äußern wenn sie darin zeit
etwas zu weit ausgelegt er belegt mit
der sie haben das wort keine sorge herr
präsident keine verwaltungsgerichte der
herr präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen wir debattieren heute über
die konferenz zur zukunft europas und
eigentlich ist der titel ja schon falsch
es geht und die konferenz zur zukunft
der eu und das ist ein unterschied denn
sie ist ja eingerichtet worden von der
eu-kommission sei die idee von ursula
von der leyen um den status quo zu
erweitern um das was genau die bürger
nicht möchten festzuschreiben unter
schaefer hat angesprochen eventuell
einen verfassungskonvent zu führen und
deswegen sollten wir uns bevor wir über
die zukunft reden mal ganz kurz die
vergangenheit der eu anschauen was ist
denn passiert die eu brüssel ist hat die
größte dichte von lobbyisten weltweit
die eu ist die institution wo gelder in
milliardenhöhe
in lobbyinteressen verschoben werden
meine damen und herren die eu ist
außerdem die institutionen die keine
freiheiten ermöglicht sondern sich immer
neue zwänge ausdenkt die von frau
löhrmann angesprochenen
schüleraustausche die sind
zurückgegangen seit es die eu in dieser
konstitution gibt dafür sind die zwänge
hoch gegangen man hat den bürgern die
glühbirnen verboten die staubsauger
verboten und jetzt verbietet man ihnen
sich frei zu bewegen oder das zu tun und
zu lassen was sie tun möchten im nur
noch als qr code inhaber ist man ein
vollwertiger mensch das digitale kurve
zertifikat auch eine erfindung der eu
kommission meine damen und herren und
diese europäischen institutionen wie sie
sind machen uns arm der euro seit seiner
einführung vor ziemlich genau 20 jahren
am ersten januar 2002 wurde das bargeld
eingeführt hat in diesem zeitraum
gegenüber der harten währung den
schweizer franken 35 prozent verloren
und die ezb drückte moment 12 einhalb
prozent der geldmenge jedes jahr nach
meine damen und herren da verwundert es
nicht dass die leute in der europäischen
union nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihr
leben finanzieren sollen wie sie ihre
miete finanzieren sollen wie sie sich
überhaupt noch ein haus kaufen sollen
das geht gar nicht diese europäische
union macht die menschen arm und
deswegen muss man leider feststellen
europas zukunft wird nur dann blöd sein
wenn diese europäische union keine
zukunft hat
doch und das wissen sie das weiß die eu
kommission und das wissen die bürger
auch deswegen haben die bürger das ja
bei als es um die abstimmung über die
europäische verfassung ging abgelehnt
und um das problem zu umgehen hat man
diese konferenz zur zukunft europas
erfunden die sogenannte partie der
partizipative demokratie das versprechen
bürger werden beteiligt können mitreden
und sie werden gehört frau löhrmann hat
sie vorhin erzählt die wahrheit das ist
ein plenum mit abgeordneten drinnen und
damit angeblich zufällig ausgewählten
bürgern wie sind die ausgewählt worden
hinterfragen wir das mal da saß kein
notar und hat personalausweis nummern
gezogen sondern das hat kann tage macht
eine organisation die in millionenhöhe
zuwendungen von der europäischen union
bekommt und die übrigens den mantel des
schweigens darüber hüllt wie diese leute
ausgewählt worden sind und wenn man
ihnen bis hinterher recherchiert dann
merkt man das sind alles überzeugte
föderalist ihnen und föderalisten
mitglieder von ngo die vereinigte
staaten von europa fordern also genau
das was die bürger europas eigentlich
nicht wollen sind diese bürger die sie
in dieses plenum hinein gesetzt haben
und jetzt spiegel sie den leuten vor
jetzt spiegel sie den leuten vor diese
zivilgesellschaft das seien die bürger
die die interessen der bürger vertreten
das ist einfach nur falsch meine damen
und herren die zivilgesellschaft
vertritt nicht die zivilisten nicht die
bürger sondern sie vertritt knallhart
genau die lobbyinteressen weshalb die
bürger ja eben genau kritisch über
brüssel denken weshalb sie brüssel
ablehnen weshalb sie die europäische
union ablehnen keiner will lobbyisten
jeder will demokratie und sie zerstören
die demokratie mit solchen aktionen
meine damen und herren
und an dieser stelle möchte ich sie
bitten haben sie den mut die bürger hier
nicht zu betrügen haben sie den mut
wirklich in den dialog mit den bürgern
zu treten haben sie den mut direkte
demokratie zu wagen wenn sie das nicht
tun
dann delegitimieren sie genau die
institutionen die wir eigentlich
erhalten wollten die institutionen die
die demokratie und die regierung tragen
aber auch die demokratie an sich denn
wenn die bürger belogen werden dann
können sie das eine vom anderen nicht
mehr unterscheiden und das wird auf
fliegen europa hat nur dann eine
blühende zukunft wenn diese europäische
union keine zukunft haben sie recht
vielen dank herr kollege
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen so
unterschiedlich können die sichtweise
sein die zu treffenden worte des
kürzlich verstorbenen präsidenten des
europäischen parlaments dabei das solid
machen uns die dimension der aufgabe
deutlich die vor uns europäerinnen und
europäern liegt unsere herausforderung
ist es eine neue welt zu schaffen nicht
weniger den herausforderungen unserer
gegenwart kann sich europa nicht mehr
entziehen wie bewältigen wir die
gesundheitlichen gesellschaftlichen und
ökonomischen folgen der andauernden
pandemie wie sichern wir unseren
planeten für zukünftige generationen
ohne wohlstand und sozialen frieden zu
gefährden und wie reagieren wir auf die
aggressionen und unseren außengrenzen
gegen unsere nachbarn und auf angriffe
auf unsere demokratischen werte die
antworten werden wir nur gemeinsam
finden und nur im dialog die zukunft
die konferenz zur zukunft europas ist
eine große chance vielleicht sogar eine
historische sie ist gelebtes europa sie
ermöglicht begegnungen und austausch und
natürlich auch die auseinandersetzung
mit neuen perspektiven
ja es ist ein experiment die libera
tiefer demokratie aber dieses experiment
schafft eine neue europäische
öffentlichkeit eine europäische
öffentlichkeit die er längst realität
ist die grenzüberschreitend denkt lebt
arbeitet studiert und liebt der mutter
der konferenz hat der staat
schwierigkeiten nicht jedes der
beteiligten länder ist schon jetzt vom
erfolg überzeugt trotz des zögerlichen
start wegen der pandemie und einer
langen diskussion über die besetzung des
exekutiv gremiums erleben wir zurzeit
eine lebendige debatte 5000
veranstaltungen
350.000 teilnehmer 13.000 digital
eingereichte zukunftsideen das ist
gelebte demokratie
wir erleben es in den bürgerforen unser
europa es den menschen nicht egal sie
wollen sich an der debatte über die
zukunft die ausrichtung unseres
kontinents beteiligung sie wollen ein
handlungsfähiges europa da seine
demokratischen werte verteidigt schauen
wir auf die ergebnisse der bürgerforen
die bürger wollen die
rechtsstaatlichkeit verordnung
verschärfen sie wollen dass die
europawahlen direkter werden und wollen
abgeordnete künftig auch über
europäische listen wählen die menschen
wollen ein europa das entscheidungen
trifft sie fordern zu recht lösungen für
die probleme die das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip mit sich bringt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen an
diskurs und input mangelt es sicher
nicht jetzt kommt es auf jeden einzelnen
an auch hier im haus für eine kluge
veränderung europas zu werden für eine
gute zukunft dieses großen projekts dann
haben die populisten in warschau oder
budapest oder auch hier am rechten rand
und am balkon keine argumente mehr für
ihren kurs gegen europa ich bin den
kollegen und der griechin axel schäfer
sehr dankbar dass sie uns dass sie den
deutschen bundestages der plenarsitzung
vertreten doch wir alle gemeinsam tragen
verantwortung dass dieses vorhaben zum
erfolg wird die heutige debatte ist ein
schritt ein schritt für mehr
öffentlichkeit sie ist aber auch
selbstverpflichtung für uns wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die empfehlungen zur
handlungs prioritäten der europapolitik
der bundesrepublik und der eu werden die
mühsame arbeit in vorschläge dürfen
nicht wieder in der schublade
verschwinden ware glaubwürdigkeit
braucht veränderung unser gemeinsames
europa ist gerade für die jungen
demokratien in unserer nachbarschaft
eine inspiration ein sehnsuchtsort ein
garant für frieden und freiheit ich
wünsche mir dass wir auch stimmen aus
unseren nachbarländern mit einbeziehen
aus den ländern für den jugend die
zukunft in der eu liegt unsere
regierungskoalition wird zum gelingen
einer konferenz zur zukunft europas
ihren beitrag leisten wir wollen unsere
europäischen partner davon überzeugen
dass die ergebnisse der konferenz
ehrlich diskutiert werden wir wollen die
notwendigen reformen zügig angehen wir
wollen dass die angestoßenen ideen zu
einem verfassungsgebenden konvent führen
der die grundlage für das europa der
zukunft schafft für einen föderalen
europäischen bundesstaat der dezentral
nach den grundsätzen der subsidiarität
und verhältnismäßigkeit
organisiert ist und er fest und
unverrückbar auf der grundrechte-charta
fust vielen dank
kaka der
nächste redner eine vereinbarten debatte
zur konferenz zur zukunft europas ist
jetzt andrej hunko haben jedoch schon im
bild der sprecher für europapolitik der
linksfraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
reden hier über die zukunft europas über
die zukunftskonferenz europas und vorhin
haben wir in der debatte über frieden in
europa gesprochen und das sind zwei
getrennte debatten und ich glaube dass
das falsch ist weil ich zutiefst davon
überzeugt bin dass europa nur eine
zukunft hat wenn es ein friedliches
europa ist
wir werden in diesem tag schmerzlich
daran erinnert durch die situation an
der grenze zwischen ukraine und russland
aber auch vielleicht durch die
entwicklungen auf dem westbalkan in
bosnien etwa das eben europa sehr viel
größer ist als nur die europäische union
die europäische union hat 27
mitgliedsstaaten zu europa gehören aber
auch die staaten des westbalkans dazu
gehört die ukraine und russland
dazu gehört auch großbritannien oder die
schweiz und deswegen denke ich dass über
eine zukunft von europa sprechen auch
über ein
gesamteuropäisches projekt reden müssen
was auch sicherheitsfragen beinhaltet
es gibt neben der europäischen union
wichtige europäische
institutionen die organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
osze
es gibt den europarat die das gesamte
den gesamten europäischen kontinent
abbilden und wenn wir aber mal auf die
proportionen schauen dann müssen wir
feststellen dass etwa der europarat ein
jahres etat hat was dem tages etat der
eu entspricht und dass zum beispiel die
osze die jetzt gerade eigentlich so
wichtig wäre ein jahres etat hat das nur
ein fünfzigstel
dessen ist was gerade beschlossen wurde
auf eu ebene nämlich ein neuer
europäischer militär von ein sogenannter
verteidigungsfonds und ich denke das
sind falsche proportionen die wir
korrigieren sollten
bei dieser konferenz zur zukunft der eu
so muss man sie ja nennen geht es
natürlich auch um wichtige themen ist es
angesprochen worden hier es geht um die
frage das einstimmigkeitsprinzip in
bestimmten politikfeldern
aufzuheben ich halte es für falsch dass
im politikfeld der außen und der
sogenannten verteidigungspolitik zu
machen weil das würde dazu führen dass
es noch leichter wären auch
perspektivisch
militärisch zu intervenieren
ich wäre sehr dafür das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip etwa im sozial-
oder im steuerbereich
aufzuheben damit es einfacher wird zum
beispiel einen europäischen mindestlohn
einzuführen damit es einfacher wird auch
große konzerne zu besteuern die hier
viel zu wenig steuern zahlen damit man
vielleicht mal auch über eine europäisch
koordinierte vermögensabgabe reden
könnte oder auch damit die reform des
dringend die dringend notwendige reform
des stabilitäts und wachstumspakts
dieser 60 3 prozent regel umgesetzt
werden könnte das halte ich eigentlich
für sehr viel zielführender
zur frage der
zukunft europas und die konferenz läuft
jetzt noch bis
in den mai hinein
ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass ist
wichtig wäre dass man auch die anderen
institutionen mit einbindet auch staaten
zb beitrittskandidaten vom westbalkan
ich würde einen konkreten vorschlag
machen unsere zwei vertreter aus dem
bundestag herr krichbaum und herrn
schäfer für die abschlusskonferenz
könnte man ja etwa die
parlamentspräsidenten von osze und
europarat einladen um diese perspektive
die perspektive des gesamteuropäischen
friedens mit einzubringen das wäre ein
konkreter vorschlag vielen dank für die
hoffnung
also ein interessantes rösler von andrej
hunko hier sprecher für europapolitik
der linksfraktion und der nächste redner
im parlament ist anton hofreiter von den
bündnisgrünen und er ist jetzt
mittlerweile vorsitzender des
ausschusses für die angelegenheiten der
europäischen union
die war doch schon mal nah dran insofern
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist einfach sehr sehr gut für die
zukunft der europäischen union das die
konferenz zur zukunft europas so
erfolgreich arbeitet entscheidend ist
jetzt dass möglichst viele es davon auch
umgesetzt wird was sich die bürgerinnen
und bürger vorstellen denn wir brauchen
eine handlungsfähige europäische union
denn die probleme sind häufig
transnational und wenn ich mir die
länder europas an schau sind die
probleme im vergleich zu ländern selbst
großen europäischen ländern wie
frankreich oder deutschland riesig es
glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft irgendjemand
das mit den herausforderungen der
globalisierung
mit den herausforderungen ökonomisch
erfolgreicher mächte allerdings
hochgradig autoritären aggressiv
auftreten der mächte wie china die
einzelnen europäischen länder alleine
klarkommen werden das wird uns nur
gelingen diesen herausforderungen bei
zukommen wenn die europäische union
handlungsfähiger wird wenn schneller zu
entscheidungen gekommen wird und wenn
die europäischen länder solidarischer
sind und dafür haben die bürgerinnen und
bürger weil sie sich ein
handlungsfähiges europa wünschen
hervorragende vorschläge gemacht und
jetzt kommt es darauf an dass wir das
die bundesrepublik deutschland dass
unsere bundesregierung alles dafür tut
dass möglichst viele es davon auch
realität wird
und wenn man sich die umfragen auch in
deutschland anschaut haben die
bürgerinnen und bürger laut umfragen
erst vor kurzem wieder angemerkt dass
die kinder grüße einen der größten laut
der umfrage die größte herausforderung
für die europäische union ist nach dafür
brauchen wir eine handlungsfähige
europäische union und ich bin ehrlich
gesagt heilfroh dass wir jetzt die
bundesregierung haben die alles tun wird
um
die eu-kommission darf zu unterstützen
dass das für 250 5 paket wo es um realen
klimaschutz geht auch wirklich umgesetzt
wird und nicht eingebremst wird und
verwässert wird und ich glaube auch dass
hier bei uns im parlament darauf ankommt
dass wir alles dafür tun dass in der
französischen ratspräsidentschaft was in
den nächsten monaten möglichst vieles
davon umgesetzt wird denn die klimakrise
wir müssen auch auf nationaler ebene
vieles tun aber die klimakrise kriegen
wir nur im griff wenn wir europäisch und
international handeln und da ist auch
entscheidend dass wir in frankreich
seite stehen eine möglichst praktikable
lösung zu finden für das was sich die
französische ratspräsidentschaft
vorgenommen habe nämlich einen
funktionierenden co2 grenze ausgleich
der sowohl klimapolitisch als auch
ökonomisch als auch in zusammenarbeit
mit den partnerinnen und partnern
funktioniert denn was ist co2 grenze
ausgleich kompliziertes wort aber wenn
in china als beispiel stahl sehr co2
reich hergestellt wird und in einem
europäischen land stahl sehr co2 arm
hergestellt wird kann es nicht sein dass
da draußen wettbewerbsnachteil wird
sondern wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
regeln so sind dass die unternehmen die
co2 frei produzieren am ende davon auch
wirklich ökonomisch profitieren damit
der kampf gegen die klimakrise sowohl
international funktioniert als auch
ökonomisch funktioniert nämlich dann
wird eine große vorbild wirkung
entfalten und
was sich die bürger und bürger auch
gewünscht haben es dass wir die werte
nach innen verteidigen und da ist der
punkt rechtsstaatlichkeit angesprochen
auch da glaube ich hörte man in den
nächsten monaten mehr tun und auch da
gibt es klare wünsche und vorstellungen
der bürgerinnen und bürger und deshalb
gilt auch dies umzusetzen
ich freue mich auf die nächsten monate
und jahre und jetzt kommt es darauf an
möglichst viel aus den guten vorschlägen
zu machen vielen dank
vielen dank herr auch der hochadel
[Applaus]
als nächste redner das wort die kollegin
dr klein sie die situation zu ihrer
ersten parlaments wählen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kolleginnen und kollegen
europa ist unsere zukunft europa ist
unser schicksal
diese feststellung unseres verstorbenen
alt bundeskanzlers helmut kohl ist
ebenso geschichtsträchtig wie
zukunftsweisend über 77 jahre lang war
die europäische integration ein garant
für frieden freiheit und wohlstand
gemeinsam haben wir europäer nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg europa wieder
aufgebaut
gemeinsam haben wir den kalten krieg und
so manche krise überwunden
stets hat mir dabei die zukunft eines
geeinten europas vor augen
wie die generation vor uns stehen wir
auch heute wieder vor der frage wie muss
eine europäische union beschaffen sein
die das versprechen von frieden
demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit und freiheit auch
zukünftig garantieren können wie
beantworten wir die großen fragen
unserer zeit wie auf den klimawandel
reagieren wie die digitalisierung von
alltag wirtschaft und verwaltung
vorantreiben wie den demografischen
wandel begegnen wie die migration im
europäischen konsens steuern wie bleiben
wir wirtschaftlich wettbewerbsfähig und
politisch relevant auf der
internationalen bühne
darauf antworten zu finden auch das ist
das ziel der konferenz zur zukunft
europas und für ein europa das weiter
zusammenwächst auch zusammen steht
müssen die europäerinnen und europäer
diesem müssen sie sich wieder an diesem
vorhaben wiederfinden und der kollege
hat es schon gesagt es ist ein ganz viel
versprechen des zeichners bis dann
360.000 menschen an rund 5000
veranstaltungen teilgenommen und mehr
als
13.000 unterschiedliche ideen
eingebracht haben wir als cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion begrüßen diese breite
beteiligung und dieses große engagement
ganz ausdrücklich denn eins ist klar
europäischer geist entsteht nicht durch
bürokratie und durch regulierungs
empfehlungen er entsteht im greifbar
wenn regen menschen konkret von denken
profitieren wenn sie sie als chance wenn
sie sie als bereicherung wahrnehmen
die europäische idee ist nur so stark
wie ihr rückhalt innerhalb der
bevölkerung der mitgliedstaaten ist wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass ein gefühl
der distanz zwischen brüssel und den
sorgen und nöten der menschen vor ort
entsteht und die bürgerkonferenz leistet
dazu einen ganz wichtigen beitrag der im
volk schon ein paar vorschläge und
forderungen gehört am letzten wochenende
hat die konferenz ja wieder
stattgefunden mit den bürgerforen und da
wurden mehr kitaplätze gefordert
sicherheit im netz verständliche
datenschutzbestimmungen aber auch mehr
demokratie bildung und sogar die
umbenennung der eu institutionen also
wir sehen wir haben ganz breite
vorschläge die da angebracht werden klar
ist die eu ist immer dort gefordert wo
wir als starke gemeinschaft mehr
erreichen können die gemeinsame
handelspolitik ist ein ganz handfestes
beispiel dafür aber auch gemeinsam
investitionen und forschung in forschung
und innovation
die stärke europas war aber auch immer
die einheit in vielfalt
der permanente wettbewerb hat uns nach
innen und nach außen stark gemacht und
das ist auch gut so denn im globalen
wirtschaftlichen wettbewerb insbesondere
mit blick auf die usa china und indien
können nationalstaaten alleine nur
schwer bestehen
und gleichzeitig brauchen wir aber auch
wir wieder mehr mut zur subsidiarität
und eigenverantwortung
für ein einiges europa brauchen wir
strukturen die nach innen einen mehrwert
schaffen und nach außen
handlungsfähigkeit gewährleisten und
dafür müssen wir auch selbstkritisch
bestehenden strukturen hinterfragen und
überprüfen vor allem müssen wir aber
dafür sorgen dass sich die stimmen der
europäerinnen und europäer gehört werden
und auch dieses haus steht in der
verantwortung darauf zu achten dass die
vorschläge der bürgerinnen und bürger
ein gang in die initiativen der eu
finden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist überzeugt
dass die konferenz in zukunft europa
eine große chance sein kann sie kann ein
auftakt für eine neue erzählung von
europa seien eine erzählung die die
vielen stimmen der bürger europas ins
zentrum rückt eine erzählung die den
kopf überzeugt und das herz berührt die
zukunft eines starken und geeinten
europas das sind wir unseren kindern
schuldig aber auch den generationen die
dieses europa aufgebaut haben wir als
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion sind bereit
vielen dank
mit ihrer ersten rede hier vor dem hohen
hause für die cdu sieht mit dem
ausschuss für die angelegenheiten der
europäischen union
der nächste redner kommt von der spd
fabian funke und auch er ist hier neu im
hause und heute mit seiner ersten rede
dann ob er ist mitglied im ausschuss für
die anleger der europäischen union farbe
im funke spd
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen für meine
generation ist die eu mehr als nur eine
abstrakte struktur oder eine politische
organisation oder die summe von
verwaltungsakten die us ein längst nicht
mehr wegzudenkender teil unseres eigenen
lebens geworden meine generation kennt
europa gar nicht anders sie ist
aufgewachsen mit offenen grenzen mit
starken austausch zwischen den regionen
mit schüleraustauschen erasmus semester
in einer gemeinsamen währung und eines
gemeinsamen arbeit und wirtschaftsraums
wir können und wollen es uns gar nicht
mehr anders vorstellen als dieses
gemeinsame europa unter dem dach der
europäischen union sie ist unser zuhause
und meines besonderes als jemand der in
einer grenzregion zu tschechien wohnt
und aufgewachsen ist und sieht wie diese
länder immer mehr zusammenwachsen wie
freundschaften entstehen wie menschen
auf arbeit pendeln und alles immer enger
wird thema dieser debatte ist aber auch
die zukunft der europäischen union und
unsere generation wird die zukunft der
europäischen union sein und sind wir
doch mal ehrlich es ist nicht alles gut
in der europäischen union die eu steht
vor großen herausforderungen und auch
bedrohungen die die zukunft europas ja
auch in den mittelpunkt die konferenz
stellt wir müssen entschlossen und
gemeinsam beim klimaschutz vorgehen wir
müssen große investitionen in
zukunftstechnologien und infrastruktur
voran bringen einerseits um die
klimakrise zu bekämpfen andererseits
aber natürlich auch um gute arbeit in
ganz europa zu sichern und die
wirtschaft fit für die zukunft zu machen
das programm fit wichtigkeit der
europäischen kommission war dazu ein
guter aufschlag den es jetzt gilt auch
mit leben zu füllen und da sind wir auch
als bundesrepublik deutschland als
wirtschafts und bevölkerungsstärkste
land in großer verantwortung aber auch
darüber hinaus müssen wir gemeinsam
dafür streiten dass die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in europa nicht
weiter von nationalisten und
nationalisten beispielsweise in polen
und ungarn unterminiert wird und dass
die europäischen werte für die
bürgerinnen und bürger auch als
europäische recht erlebbar und sicher
werden
und das bedeutet auch ganz klar weil die
verantwortung endet ja nicht an den
europäischen außengrenzen wir müssen das
sterben im mittelmeer beenden wir müssen
europa auf den weg zu einer
menschenwürdigen aufnahmen politik
bringen die die menschen im mittelmeer
rettet und die humanitären standards
unsere union an den außengrenzen sichert
situation wie in moria oder an der
polnischen grenze dürfen nicht unser
anspruch sein die europäische union muss
nach innen und nach außen ihre
humanitären demokratischen und
rechtsstaatlichen ansprüchen gerecht
werden sie darf sich nicht von
autokratischen drittstaaten mit
migrationsströme ablesbar machen sie
darf nicht tatenlos dabei zusehen wie
mitgliedstaaten demokratische grundwerte
stück zu stück zurück rollen und sie
muss in der außen und sicherheitspolitik
handlungsfähig sein das sehen wir gerade
mal wieder besonders kurzum wir brauchen
europäische souveränität und deswegen
ist es auch sehr sehr gut und ich freue
mich sehr dass die französische
ratspräsidentschaft das jetzt in den
mittelpunkt stellt und
dinge wie der austritt des vereinigten
königreichs zeigen uns schmerzlich wie
fragil die europäische union auch sein
kann und auch in den anderen ländern
machen sich nationalisten breit die
unsere vorstellung des gemeinsamen
lebens in der europäischen union in
frage stellen und da bin ich
insbesondere froh dass in diesem haus
zumindestens unter den meisten
fraktionen mit expliziter ausnahme
dieser fraktion hier rechts und
parlament eine große einigkeit darüber
besteht dass wir die europäische union
brauchen und weiter entwickeln müssen um
noch enger zusammen zu wachsen
und deshalb müssen wir in der
europäischen union noch stärker
zueinander hinten weiter zusammenwachsen
und die bürgerinnen und bürger auf dem
weg aber da auch mitnehmen weil nur mit
beteiligungen akzeptanz schaffen wir
weiteres wohlbefinden für die weitere
integration der europäischen union und
damit bin ich auch sehr sehr froh dass
dieser prozess zur zukunft der
europäischen union in so einer breiten
diskussion zwischen rat kommission
parlament und mit den bürgerinnen und
bürgern da draußen in diesem land
stattfindet und man finde man kann die
ergebnisse können sich auch sehen lassen
wir müssen aber auch die
parlamentarische beteiligung in der
europäischen union stärken wir brauchen
eine reform des europäischen parlamentes
und transnationale listen das ist ja
auch das was die menschen nach draußen
fordern die zukunft der bundesrepublik
muss eine europäische sein um die
herausforderungen einer globalisierten
welt meistern zu können lassen sie uns
also gemeinsam daran arbeiten und dafür
sorgen dass meine und zukünftige
generationen in einem vereinten souverän
und gerechten europa aufwachsen können
vielen dank
[Applaus]
die pause auch für ihn und seine erste
rede hier in der debatte zur konferenz
zur zukunft europas die ergebnisse
sollen im mai vorgelegt werden
dass sitzungspräsident oder
sitzungsdienst achten sehr genau dass
die idee nicht von der masse pflicht
befreit sind auch ihre masken tragen wir
sind für jeden hinweis dankbar aber das
müsse nicht jeder hinweis erfolgen
vielleicht dass man so sagen nichts
trainer wird der kollege sei von der fw
fraktion sein der von der tribüne
spricht
größer weil die kinder spielen nicht
wenn ihre redezeit ich meinen er bekomme
sie zwei minuten vor schluss eine
optische signale die regenzeit läuft
dann runter sie haben das wort parat
weil der europapolitische sprecher der
hfg die von makro initiierte
zukunftskonferenz soll ja direkt zu
laufen auf einen neuen
verfassungskonvent mit der
verschlimmbesserung dass qualifizierte
mehrheit entscheidet die letzten veto
möglichkeiten verhindern sollen es geht
hierbei vor allem um außenpolitik und
steuerhoheit mit zeitgemäßer panik
rhetorik in einfacher sprache also klima
corona russland china und so weiter im
ampel koalitionsvertrag steht sogar
einigermaßen verfassungswidrig die
gründung eines eu bundesstaates und
durch den abgang großbritanniens hat
sich die sache mit dem veto ja schon von
selbst erledigt längst sind die
nettozahler in der qualifizierten
minderheit angekommen mit der augen
wischen zukunftskonferenz wird hier nur
ein mäßiges weiter so
verschleiert der englische erfinder des
nation branding seinen anholt redet der
ende 2011 vor brüsseler berufs europäern
zu den grenzen von werbung und
propaganda die eu
kommunikationsstrategie zeichnet sich
demnach dadurch aus dass sie zitat
erstens informationen verbreitet nachdem
keiner fragt zweitens werbung betreibt
obwohl sie kein produkt hat drittens
nicht weiß wer ihre kunden sind und
viertens die ganze zeit nur geld
verschwenderische propaganda betreibt
diese vor sich her laufende
zukunftskonferenz nun ist eine besonders
dreiste suggestion homöopathischer
bürgerbeteiligung es wird so getan als
ob der ganze apparat einen echten
änderungs willen hätte es hat den
charakter einer art paartherapie und
zwar nach einer fast 66 jahre
andauernden gewalt und missbrauch
beziehung die fast nur einseitigen
betrug und ausbeutung kennt einen
missbrauch beziehung zwischen politik
arad und zahlenden publikum welches
immer weniger leistung für immer mehr
beitrag bekommt national wie
international
das ganze kann die immer nur eine
richtung nämlich die falsche hier aber
nun unsere glasklaren vorschläge wie
eine wünschenswerte eu zukunft aussehen
müsste erster rückführung des brüsseler
ep zu einer echt parlamentarischen
versammlung aller europarat oder
französisch deutsche versammlung mit
maximal der hälfte der derzeitigen
abgeordneten bezahlt nach nationalen
diäten und alle abgeordneten haben zu
kommen aus national verantwortlichen und
gewählten parlamenten so wie es ja auch
die urform des geschehens in brüssel vor
1979 war des weiteren
angleichung der gehälter nicht in dem
sinne wie es 2009 erfolgt ist alle
bekommen das gleiche exorbitant
brüsseler spitzengehälter sondern es
wird bezahlt nach nationalen diäten plus
spesen fertig und drittes und letztes
zunächst die rückführung des
agrarbereichs in nationale verantwortung
und beendigung einer völlig
überdimensionierten über griffigkeit im
finanzbereich und endlich eine klare
überfällige aufgaben beschränkungen aus
der sich alles weitere ergibt machen wir
uns bitte sofort
auf den weg in diese gute und bessere eu
zukunft die beweist dass man lernfähig
und lernwillig ist dieser beweis ist zu
führen wir stehen bereit sie oft mal ich
danke
vielen dank herr kollege hause weil
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin dr
jurisch fdp fraktion zu ihrer ersten
chance
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
innerhalb der europäischen union regen
frieden und wohlstand unser leben es ist
heute aber erst 77 jahre her dass das
konzentrationslager auschwitz befreit
wurde meine eltern haben noch als kleine
kinder das grauen des von deutschland
verschuldeten krieges miterlebt
heute debattieren wir hier über die
konferenz zur zukunft europas heute
debattieren wir wie wir in der eu in
zukunft auch in zukunft in frieden und
sozial ökologisch und wirtschaftlich
stabil leben können in den foren der
konferenz für die zukunft europas haben
sich menschen sehr selbstbewusst dafür
engagiert vision zu entwickeln und
lösungsansätze zu formulieren ihnen gilt
unser großer dank und ihren einsatz für
ihre sehr wertvolle arbeit
ich möchte hier dafür werben dass wir
auch im bundestag die dynamik der
zukunftskonferenz und der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft für die
weiterentwicklung der eu flankieren und
unterstützen europa ist noch nicht
fertig der weg zu mehr europäischer
stärken integration führt sowohl über
reformen auf institutioneller ebene als
auch über mehr vernetzung zwischen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern mehr
wissensaustausch mehr
informationsaustausch mehr persönliche
begegnungen darin sind noch viel
potenzial für eine innere stärkung und
weitere entfaltung der eu
deshalb richtig diesen aspekt der
besseren vernetzung von menschen und
ideen hier und heute besonders in den
fokus rücken die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer der zukunftskonferenz des
deutschen forums dieser konferenz haben
dazu auch einige ganz konkrete
vorschläge erarbeitet
beispielsweise schlagen sie vor dass ein
eu weites bildungs und
informationsmedium einzurichten sei das
eine informationsplattform für best
practice in der aus und weiterbildung
aufgesetzt werden solle und dass der
schüleraustausch zwischen allen eu
ländern intensiviert und unabhängig vom
einkommen der eltern gestaltet werden
sollen als europäerin
als europäerin möchte ich zu mehr
vernetzung von menschen und ideen doch
aus ganz persönlicher sicht ergänzen
gerade auch die grenznahen räume
innerhalb
europas also beispielsweise der
bodenseeregion in der ich lebe verdienen
unsere aufmerksamkeit wenn ich dort wie
soll es dann zwischen grenz ferneren
regionen klappen oft hapert es an ganz
praktischen dingen der mangelhafte
ausbau zb von grenzüberschreitenden
verkehrswegen verhindern den austausch
von menschen und ideen
bürokratische erschwernisse bei der
grenzüberschreitend von dienstleistern
verhindern eine wirtschaftliche
integration
und ungenutztes potenzial bei der
grenzüberschreitenden zusammenarbeit von
institutionen bremsen die volle
entfaltung von region als
bundestagsabgeordnete werde ich mich
stark dafür machen dass die
weiterentwicklung der eu für die
bürgerinnen und bürger greifbar wird
gerade auch durch mehr vernetzung von
menschen und ideen
mit vielen wegweisenden auch ganz
praktischen ideen an der europäischen
zukunftskonferenz beteiligt wirken auch
wir hier im bundestag darauf hin dass
die ergebnisse der konferenz für eine
umfassende weiterentwicklung genutzt
werden bis hin zu den vertraglichen
grundlagen der europäischen union genau
das ist eine zentrale europapolitische
forderung in unserem ampel
koalitionsvertrag und als liberale freue
ich mich darüber sehr
ich möchte meine erste rede in diesem
haus nicht enden ohne danke zu sagen
danke für ihr europäisches parlament
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger für ein
starkes verletztes und demokratisches
europa als liberale und freidemokraten
erfüllt mich der frieden innerhalb der
eu in grafit großer dankbarkeit die
aktuelle lage zeigt uns dass dieser
friede keine selbstverständlichkeit ist
lassen sie uns jeden tag und überall
weiter daran arbeiten vielen dank
diskutiert über die zukunft konferenz
zur zukunft europas da soll es ja bürger
debatten geben gibt es auch schon
eigentlich vor ort ursprünglich geplant
viel ist jetzt ins netz verlegt wegen
corona natürlich
das allgemeine anregungen und das
nächste mal spreche ich persönlichkeiten
unmittelbaren nächster redner wurde ich
noch gar nicht aufgerufen hatte aber
schon da ist der kollege robin wagner
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der friede der
welt kann nicht gewahrt werden ohne
schöpferische anstrengung anstrengungen
die der größe der bedrohung entsprechen
mit diesem satz hat der damalige
französische außenminister robert
schuman am 9 mai 1950 den grundstein für
das größte friedensprojekt aller zeiten
gelegt die europäische union
dass wir heute am tag des gedenkens an
die opfer des nationalsozialismus über
die zukunft europas diskutieren das ist
für mich von großer bedeutung
wir alle wissen welch unermessliches
leid die shoah und der zweite weltkrieg
für millionen von menschen bedeutet hat
und teilweise bis heute bedeutet wir
alle wissen dass aus dieser historischen
schuld auch immer eine besondere
verantwortung deutschlands für die
zukunft europas und für ein friedliches
miteinander
erwachsen wird innerhalb der
europäischen union wir den frieden durch
eine immer engere zusammenarbeit durch
friedliches zusammenwachsen über grenzen
hinweg gesichert für uns ist frieden
heute gelebte selbstverständlichkeit
in ganz europa und in unserer direkten
nachbarschaft ist es das nicht bis heute
ist der frieden auf dem westbalkan
brüchig bis heute sind dort mancherorts
menschen an der macht die den genozid
von srebrenica leugnen oder verharmlosen
seit 2004 10 erleben wir den krieg in
der ost ukraine und in belarus zählen
wir heute 1000 politische gefangene
1000 menschen die für ihren kampf für
demokratie mit der freiheit bezahlen ein
trauriger rekord ich habe selbst eine
patenschaft übernommen für die halo sich
eine oppositionellen journalisten
29 jahre alt er hat eine dreijährige
tochter
er konnte nicht miterleben wie seine
tochter paulina laufen lernte er konnte
nicht miterleben wie sie sprechen lernte
weil er mehr als die hälfte ihres lebens
im gefängnis sitzt unschuldig
und es sind diese individuellen
geschichten von menschen die uns vor
augen führen wie wichtig es ist uns für
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
einzusetzen innerhalb
[Applaus]
und das innerhalb der europäischen union
wo wir uns weiter mit ganzer energie
dafür einsetzen werden die werte der eu
demokratie rechtsstaatlichkeit mensch
schlecht menschlichkeit auch selbst zu
leben und das in allen politikfeldern
mit einem klaren kompass
aber eben auch in der europäischen
nachbarschaft die menschen in bosnien
und herzegowina in der ukraine in
belarus sie zählen auf uns und auch
deshalb wird die koalition ein
besonderes augenmerk auf diese region
legen und den menschen in ihrem einsatz
für frieden demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit beistehen ich freue
mich sehr dass die konferenz zur zukunft
der europäischen union sich mit der
rolle der eu in der welt beschäftigt und
dabei wird beispielsweise intensiv über
eine häufigere anwendung von
qualifizierten mehrheitsentscheidungen
in der außenpolitik diskutiert und das
klingt erstmal technischer was hat sehr
konkrete auswirkungen denn das bedeutet
dass das veto eines einzelnen staates
nicht mehr die komplette
handlungsfähigkeit der eu lahm legen
kann die zukunftskonferenz ist eine
einzigartige chance um mit vielen
bürgerinnen und bürgern ins gespräch zu
kommen nutzen wir sie nutzen wir sie für
eine stärkung des parlaments für eine
weitere intensive bürgerbeteiligung
nutzen wir sie um die uno eu noch
handlungsfähiger strategisch souveräner
und noch stärker zu einem europa der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu machen vielen
dank
vielen dank
robin wagner der europapolitische
sprecher der grünen fraktion war dass
die konferenz zur zukunft europas sollte
er ursprünglich zwei jahre dauern
allerdings wurde der start verschoben
trotzdem bleibt ist dabei der
abschlussbericht soll dieses frühjahr
fertig sein von daher werden wir im
frühjahr hier wohl noch weitere debatten
da zu hören jetzt aber erst einmal
tobias winkler für die unionsfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
konferenz zur zukunft europas ist mit
dem rückenwind gestartet aus der letzten
europawahl 2009 10 sind über 200
millionen bürgerinnen und bürger an die
wahlurne gegangen und haben dem
europäischen parlament ihre stimme
verliehen die bürgerinnen und bürger wie
spüren das ziel dieses europa
mitgestalten müssen mitgestalten wollen
europa ist gegründet von mutigen
politikern von vordenkern robert
schumann harmonien als jede gasparri
viele wurden hier auch schon heute schon
genannt später auch helmut kohl auch
angela merkel jean claude juncker viele
die dieses europa stark vorangebracht
haben und ich habe den eindruck dass die
politiker die vorgedacht haben die die
menschen mitgenommen haben heutzutage
etwas weniger mut haben und von den
menschen getrieben werden die menschen
wollen mehr und ein stärkeres und ein
demokratischeres europa und deswegen
freue ich mich frau staatsministerin man
wenn man dass sie sagen wir wollen die
ergebnisse dieser konferenz ernst nehmen
ich habe auch hier in meiner kurzen
zugehörigkeit zu diesem hause schon
erlebt die besondere gabe von
abgeordneten auch von
regierungsmitgliedern das sonntagsreden
auch unter der woche gehalten werden
können ich hoffe sehr dass die
ernsthaftigkeit mit der die ergebnisse
der konferenz zur zukunft europas
behandelt werden nicht zu dieser
kategorie gehören sondern dass wir uns
damit auseinandersetzen was die
bürgerinnen bürger in vielen foren
diskutieren und an ideen einbringen
die zahlen wurden schon genannt
350 und über 350.000 bürgerinnen
bürgerinnen die sich beteiligt haben in
über 5000 veranstaltungen
ich finde es etwas schade aber es bleibt
noch zeit sozusagen jetzt als kritik
aber auch als ermutigung dass das
europäische parlament und die
europäische kommission sehr viel in
diesem prozess einbringen die diese
bürgerforen organisieren die
veranstaltung mit organisieren die viele
partner aus der zivilgesellschaft auch
animieren und unterstützen bei ihrer
arbeit die bundesregierung aber auch die
länder wie es auch heute schon
angesprochen wurden wurde sind noch
nicht auf diesen zug aufgesprungen das
was bisher organisiert wurde reicht noch
nicht den menschen in deutschland und in
vielen anderen ländern ist in den
überwiegend großen mehrheit nicht
bekannt was für ein großartiges was für
ein zukunftsweisendes projekt direkter
bürgerbeteiligung hier ins leben gerufen
wurden wir müssen wenn wir mehr menschen
daran beteiligen wollen dann müssen wir
das auf allen ebenen spielen wir haben
wenn das ende der konferenz mit dem
schlussbericht um den europatag zum 9
mai stattfinden soll zumindest und der
französische ratspräsidentschaft noch
einige monate zeit ich glaube es wäre an
es wäre angebracht wenn die
bundesregierung und die länder hier
nochmal einen schub reinsetzen und
nochmal die bürgerinnen und bürger
animieren an der konferenz teilzunehmen
und für diese werben
wir erleben das jetzt in der auch in der
heutigen diskussion viele der ideen die
die bürgerinnen bürgerinnen einbringen
schon vereinnahmt werden zu politischen
forderungen die dann hier noch mal
noch mal zu papier gebracht werden oder
in der in der rede vor gebracht werden
das ist glaube ich nicht der punkt wie
wir damit umgehen sollen wir sollten die
bürgerinnen und bürger ermutigen wir
dürfen mit unseren ideen
selbstverständlich die diskussion mit
beeinflussen wir dürfen auch die
ganz konkret an diesen an diesen
konferenzen mit teilnehmen aber wir
sollten nicht sozusagen unsere ideen
dann mit einem mit der rechtfertigung
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger dies
alles gefordert hätten durch bringen
sondern wir müssen auch die bürgerinnen
und bürger hören und daraus unsere
schlüsse ziehen ich sehe in dieser
konferenz zur zukunft europas eine
großartige chance und ich hoffe dass wir
sie auch künftig als solche wahrnehmen
und so behandeln vielen dank
da hat hier noch einmal darauf
hingewiesen wie mit den ideen mit den
vorschlägen der zukunftskonferenz
umgegangen werden soll eine
verpflichtung zur umsetzung dieser
reform vorschläge im gibt es nicht das
heißt
wir werden sehen inwieweit diese ideen
dann auch gehör finden bei den
entscheidungsträgern johannes jetzt für
die als resident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen eine gut
funktionierende demokratie beruht in
erster linie auf vertrauen vertrauen
durch mitspracherecht und durch
mitsprachemöglichkeiten ein
mitspracherecht haben wir als
staatsbürger in den europäischen
demokratien ganz automatisch
aber nicht alle wissen immer so ganz
genau wie sie das wie sie dieses recht
auch sinnvoll ausüben können deshalb
müssen immer wieder möglichkeiten zur
mitsprache geschaffen und dabei immer
wieder auch neue wege gegangen werden
wenn man ein konkretes anliegen hat dann
kann man sich beispielsweise an seinen
örtlichen bundestagsabgeordneten wenden
dies erfreulich viele menschen tun oder
man kann das parlamentarische
petitionsrecht nutzen die mitglieder des
petitionsausschusses kümmern sich sehr
sorgfältig darum oder man kann im rahmen
der europäischen der band kann sich im
rahmen der konferenz zur zukunft europas
beteiligen denn auch sie ist ein solcher
weg die eigene meinung einzubringen
mit zu sprechen und sie ist wie wir von
unseren beiden teilnehmerinnen des
bundestages gunther krichbaum und axel
schäfer gehört haben ein guter und
erfolgreicher weg liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
neben der einbindung der
zivilgesellschaft und im intensiven
austausch von bürgerinnen und bürgern
aus allen teilen des kontinents zu
zahlreichen themen bietet die
zukunftskonferenz aber auch uns
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentariern
die möglichkeit unseren kurs in
bestimmten fragestellungen nochmals zu
überprüfen und hier möchte ich als
konkretes beispiel auch noch nur noch
mal auf das stichwort
rechtsstaatlichkeit eingehen viele
vorredner und vorrednerin haben es
zurecht angesprochen noch mich hat
dieses thema in den letzten jahren hier
im bundestag intensiv beschäftigt auch
bei der zukunftskonferenz setzt sich
eine arbeitsgruppe mit werten und
rechten mit rechtsstaatlichkeit und
sicherheit in europa auseinander neben
den diskussionen zwischen den zufällig
ausgewählten bürgerinnen und bürgern
vertretern der zivilgesellschaft und
abgeordneten aus den verschiedensten
politischen ebenen wurden auch tausende
beiträge von bürgerinnen und bürgerinnen
und zu diesem thema auf der
online-plattform der zukunftskonferenz
erfasst und ich finde die ergebnisse
dieser beiträge ungemein beeindruckend
kollege hacker hat es vorhin auch schon
angesprochen eine ganz große gruppe von
teilnehmenden fordert sehr deutlich die
achtung der rechtsstaatlichkeit und
einen besseren schutz der grundwerte in
der europäischen union in manchen
beiträgen werden beispielsweise sehr
große bedenken hinsichtlich der
einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher kriterien
beispielsweise mit blick auf ungarn und
polen geäußert bedenken gegenüber
staatsform die sich selbst als liberal
bezeichnet
andererseits muss man auch konstatieren
das ist einige beiträge gibt die dazu
auffordern die nationalen
angelegenheiten dieser länder zu
respektieren da wird beispielsweise auf
das demokratische recht ungarns
verwiesen seine grenzen zu verteidigen
seine christliche religion kultur oder
auch eine homogene gesellschaft zu
bewahren
einige teilnehmende schlagen vor die
finanzielle unterstützung für länder zu
kürzen die gegen gemeinsame rechtsstaats
kriterien verstoßen das stimmrecht im
europäischen rat zu entziehen oder sogar
ihre mitgliedschaft in der europäischen
union zu beenden es wird debattiert ob
der europäische gerichtshof die rolle
eines wächters über demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der eu übernehmen
soll und auch wie der haushalts
schutzmechanismus genutzt werden soll um
regierungen die gegen europäische
grundwerte verstoßen besser
sanktionieren zu können außerdem wird
ein überprüfungs mechanismus für
demokratie rechtsstaatlichkeit und
grundrechte in der eu gefordert es wird
also intensivst über verschiedene
standpunkte diskutiert ebenso wie wir
das als parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier in den ausschüssen oder
eben hier im plenum tun
abgesehen davon dass die konditionalität
regelungen zum schutz des eu haushaltes
für die wir viele jahre lang hat hier im
bundestag kämpfen musste nur die wir
während der deutschen
eu-ratspräsidentschaft endlich
implementieren konnten offensichtlich
größtenteils ganz im sinne der
europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger ist
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
abgesehen davon wird für mich eines an
dieser zukunftskonferenz ganz deutlich
die europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger
wollen ein demokratisches europa eines
dass sie stark nach innen sowie nach
außen vertritt und ganz viele nehmen die
möglichkeit zur mitsprache durch ihre
beteiligung an der zukunftskonferenz war
noch ist die zukunftskonferenz nicht
abgeschlossen und natürlich kann eine
solche konferenz kann kein allheilmittel
für alle möglichen übel und
schwierigkeiten seien mit denen wir ohne
frage auch in europa zu kämpfen haben
eines ist diese konferenz aber ganz
sicher sie ist ein ausgezeichneter
ausgangspunkt um wir unsere gemeinsame
zukunft zu sprechen in vielen
themenbereichen entscheidende weichen zu
stellen und die konferenz wie wir das
auch in unserem koalitionsvertrag
beschrieben haben für notwendige
reformen und eine weiterentwicklung
europas zu nutzen und nicht zuletzt um
auch mitsprachemöglichkeiten das
mitspracherecht und damit das
demokratische miteinander zu stärken mit
der heutigen debatte
haben wir ebenfalls unseren beitrag dazu
geleistet vielen herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
damit werden sich die aussprache der
tagesordnungspunkt ist ledig